the reason that they do not want the
flag due to its Origins with the
Reverend slavery and slave trade 12 year
old Jaden was in big trouble at school
why well Jaden and his mom got called
into a meeting at the school over this
patch on his backpack it's the Gadsden
flag a rattlesnake with the caption
don't tread on me school officials say
it's a racist flag due to its Origins
with slavery in the slave trade is that
true nope the Gadsden flag comes from
the Revolutionary War and was intended
as a symbol of resistance to British
tyranny today it's used by classical
liberals and Libertarians including
reason.com some Lefty groups have cited
Gaston too there's even a pro-lgbt
version don't take my word for it
Colorado governor Jared Polis a Democrat
describes the flag as quote a proud
symbol of the American Revolution now
school officials have since relented and
Jaden is back in class I'm glad to hear
it don't tread on a kid's Free Speech
rights